it was the weekend images emerging from
butcher which prompted this meeting of
the security Council they'd invited
Vladimir zielinski to join them but were
not prepared for what he would show them
what they saw in the chamber cannot be
broadcast here but the images of dead
bodies are horrific they're from several
towns across Ukraine some of them
charred hands tied behind backs women
and children among them we cannot yet
independently verify the context behind
them but the pattern is clear killings
Mass executions rapes
zielinski called for Russia with its
power to veto anything this place tries
to do be removed from the council
remove Russia as an aggressor and a
source of War
so it cannot block decisions about its
own aggression its own War
but there is no mechanism for Russia's
removal and so its top Diplomat is free
to claim that all these allegations are
nonsense you say it's all fabrication
what's happening in butcher
it's all a fabrication I said I said I
said that this this photographs appeared
only on the 3rd of April while we left
the place on the city of March but the
the satellite evidence shows those
bodies were there when you were in
charge of that town
it's not true
nothing today can be taken for granted
okay and don't forget that the video
that President zielinski displayed today
is a fake read my Twitter this is what
why is it fake because it is a fake it
was the people are not dead the people
are dead but they were shot elsewhere
where there were no Russian troops it
was it appeared before read the internet
read the users the UK holds the current
presidency of the security Council and
had called the Urgent meeting I suspect
that the security Council has never seen
a video with such horrifying images on
it I don't think there's any reason to
doubt those images the important thing
now is that there is accountability for
what is clearly war crimes
from this top body down Russia is truly
isolated now and yet The Killing goes on
the focus ahead is to build a case
against it to counter the denials with
facts and evidence Mark Stone Sky News
in New York